- Americans pay a lot for their medicine,
and it only seems to be getting worse.
US spending on prescription
drugs has increased by 76%
in the last 20 years.
Today we pay around twice as much
as other wealthy nations on average.
- This can have devastating effects
on the individuals who rely on them,
with one in three Americans reporting
that they skipped prescribed medications
because of the cost.
Many others have gone into debt
or even suffered bankruptcy
over high drug prices.
- But there is another option
that Americans are increasingly
taking advantage of,
buying prescription drugs
from other countries.
The practice is not without
health and legal risks,
but the price differences can be so huge
it's understandable
that people are willing
to take a gamble.
For many it might be the only way
to access life-saving medications.
- But before you pop
over the Mexican border
for some insulin,
or log onto a Canadian
website for asthma inhalers,
you should know how much
you can really save,
whether the risks are worth the reward,
and how we got into this
mess in the first place.
- Why are drugs so expensive in the US?
The short answer is that
here pharmaceutical companies
are allowed to charge whatever they want.
Virtually all other wealthy
nations have regulatory bodies
that determine how much
new drugs can cost,
based on how medically effective they are.
If the drug company
doesn't like the price cap,
the drug won't get approved.
- By contrast, the FDA
must approve every drug
as long as it's considered
safe and effective,
and has no say in the price.
Individual insurers and
hospitals can negotiate
with drug companies, but because
the market is so fractured,
they don't have much leverage.
The only organization big enough
to throw its weight around, Medicare,
is legally prohibited from haggling.
They're required by law
to cover nearly every
drug the FDA approves
at whatever price the
drug companies ask for,
the upshot is that Americans have access
to a much wider range of prescriptions
but at prices so high
they're effectively inaccessible to many.
- It's not surprising that
many Americans have decided,
"Hey, if my government won't
do anything about drug prices,
I'll just buy from a country that will,"
this can mean dropping into a pharmacy
while on vacation abroad,
or ordering from an international website.
It's surprisingly easy,
and there are a lot of
savings to be found,
especially on name-brand drugs.
So why not go for it?
Well, for one thing, it's illegal.
- US law prohibits the importation
of prescription medication
from other countries,
even those that are FDA-approved
and manufactured in America.
But in reality you're very unlikely
to get into trouble for it.
The FDA specifically allows
agents to overlook infractions,
as long as the quantity is
obviously for personal use,
say, three months worth,
and the drug doesn't pose
any serious health risks.
- Although the possibility
of legal jeopardy
might not be much of a deterrent,
there are still health
and safety risks involved.
- To talk about them,
we've invited some real
healthcare professionals
on the show.
Dr. Alok Patel and Sheena
Williams from PBS Vitals.
- It's true, brand-name
prescription prices in the US
far exceed those of many other countries.
And as we've been hearing
from Philip and Julia,
in most cases, importing
prescription drugs into the US
for personal use is
prohibited and illegal.
Some might say that's to
protect pharma's bottom line
but the safety issues are very real.
- Here's an interesting fact,
according to the World
Health Organization,
one in 10 medical products found
in low and middle-income countries
are either substandard or counterfeit.
In a separate study, scientists found
that up to 41% of tested
drugs purchased abroad
failed quality specification,
that says something about the
oversight from the US FDA,
which is really considered
the gold standard
around the world.
(upbeat music)
(water slurping)
- But for some the financial
benefits outweigh the risks.
If you're in the market
to buy prescription drugs
outside the US, here are
some helpful tips for you
to be able to spot a counterfeit.
Number one, get a prescription
from a US physician
and make sure you're familiar
with the medication's size,
shape, color, and taste.
If there are cracks,
discoloration, or stickiness,
throw those away, as they're
probably counterfeit.
Check out these counterfeits,
notice how the label and print
have different font styles
and printing patterns.
Also, in some cases
the drugs might be smaller
or larger in shape.
Pills should be in
their original packaging
and not loose or in a
plastic bag or envelope,
that'd be just weird.
The most common counterfeit
prescription drugs
include erectile dysfunction drugs
such as Viagra, Levitra, and Cialis.
Cholesterol medication like Lipitor,
diet pills, antihistamines, antivirals
like those used to treat HIV and AIDS,
and expensive chemotherapeutic drugs.
- You also want to consider
that not all countries are the same
when it comes to making your purchase.
Oversight in some places is
a lot better than others,
your odds are a lot better
if your meds are coming
from well-regulated countries
like Canada, New Zealand,
Australia, Turkey, or
most of Western Europe.
Another thing to look out for,
double-check that the pharmacy
you are purchasing your medicine from
is licensed in the country of origin.
There are several resources
to find safer and
affordable medicines abroad.
The Canadian International
Pharmacy Association runs a site
that can help you find
legitimate certified pharmacies.
Another option is pharmacychecker.com.
They compare prices
and the legitimacy of prescription drugs,
available online and abroad.
Finally, check out the
Medicines Quality Database
by the US Pharmacopeial Convention.
They've compiled alerts issued
for poor-quality medicines
found in Africa, Asia,
Eastern Europe, Latin America,
and the Caribbean.
- One more thing, if you've
been prescribed something
that is outside your price range,
ask your doctor for a
generic prescription.
A recent study found
that 88% of the most commonly
prescribed generic drugs
in the United States
were almost 68% cheaper
than purchasing a generic in
Canada, what's up with that?
- If you want more information
about medical tourism,
come on over to Vitals
- Back to you, dynamic duo at Two Cents
- Beyond your own personal health,
both medical and financial,
there's another reason
that some discourage
the practice of buying cheap drugs abroad,
it's bad for the industry.
Pharmaceutical companies claim
that they're high prices are reflective
of the steep cost of research
and development of new drugs.
If everyone paid low prices,
they'd have to cut back
on developing new drugs
for serious ailments
like cancer and Alzheimer's.
"I know you want a good bargain
but you're not on the side of cancer,
are you?"
- Boo!
- This is the same argument they use
against any kind of price
controls or regulation,
that it will stifle the future
of pharmaceutical research,
beside the fact that they're
basically asking Americans
to subsidize low prices
for the rest of the world,
there are some reasons to be
dubious about this explanation.
- For one thing, prices have
been rising steadily on drugs
that haven't changed in decades,
and thus require no
research and development,
that would be like if Apple
never updated their iPhone
since 2008, but raised the
price on it every year,
you'd only buy that if
your life depended on it.
- Also, despite claims of high
costs, recent analysis found
that drug companies actually have plenty
of financial wiggle room.
They make more than enough money
to cover the costs of R&D,
and have enough leftover
for large profit margins.
Many other companies
like auto manufacturers spend more on R&D
with smaller profit margins.
- In fact, of the top 10
pharmaceutical companies,
nine spend more on
marketing than research.
That's right, those incessant ads
that tell you to ask your doctor
if such and such is right for you,
are more responsible for high drug prices
than the cost of innovation,
which means we could
have fewer of those ads
and lower drug prices?
Sounds like a win-win to me.
- Growing more frustrated with high prices
and more skeptical of
the industry's excuses,
a majority of Americans now
support the legalization
of importing drugs from other countries.
In 2021, the Biden administration
signed an executive order
allowing states to legally
purchase inexpensive drugs
from Canada, which could be good news
for millions of patients
burdened by high drug prices.
- And yet there's something strange
about the whole situation.
Rather than just regulating
the price of drugs here,
we're going to let people
import America- made drugs
from other countries that are
willing to regulate prices?
- It does seem ridiculous,
especially considering
that the vast majority
of Americans also support
some kind of regulation on drug prices
but the pharmaceutical industry
still has a lot of sway in Washington,
and it's much easier to kill
a bill than to pass one.
- Meanwhile, millions
of Americans are forced
to weigh their health needs
against practices that may be
medically or legally risky.
It may not be a viable long-term solution,
but in the current American
healthcare landscape,
you can't blame people for
doing what they need to survive.
- [Both] And that's our two cents.
- If you want more info and advice
on navigating the crazy, confusing,
but mortally important
world of healthcare,
head over to PBS Vitals.